Transcriptor: Federica Bruno
Revisor: Larisa Esteche
Escribía mi disertación sobre literatura.
Cuando recibí el mensaje
de una amiga cercana,
entre todas las novedades que me contaba,
me decía que pronto sería
la editora de una revista
de contenido social.
Yo me emocioné muchísimo con esta noticia
y le dije que me avisara que yo podía
enviarle un artículo sobre literatura
para su publicación.
Después de unos pocos días, ella
me contesta con una negativa
rotunda a mi propuesta.
Me dice, “No, no, no, cari.
En nuestra revista solo publicamos cosas
que sirvan a la sociedad”.
Cosas que sirvan a la sociedad.
Esta frase resonó en mi mente porque
después de todo, yo he dedicado mucho
tiempo de mi vida al estudio de algo que
la mayoría de la gente considera no tiene
valor alguno.
Inmediatamente me puse a pensar en las
respuestas que quería decirle a mi amiga,
explicarle las razones detrás del rol
fundamental de la literatura.
Decirle, por ejemplo,
que la literatura
es la forma más alta
de la expresión del lenguaje humano.
Y entonces, con este razonamiento ya
imagínense ustedes la importancia
que tiene la literatura.
Sin embargo, todavía no encontraba mayores
razones para decirle
que la literatura es más que el cúmulo
de historias que nos llevan a mundos
ficticios e intangibles.
Porque si bien la literatura nos hace
suspirar con historias románticas, nos
permite ser los investigadores y resolver
el crimen perfecto en una novela policial.
Y también la literatura nos permite
explorar con la imaginación
mundos de vampiros y lobos.
La literatura además de lúdica también
puede ser un instrumento que aporte
al desarrollo social.
Cuando todavía seguía pensando las
respuestas que le iba a dar a mi amiga,
se presentó esta situación que todos
tenemos,
la vida y la experiencia
te darán las respuestas.
Y por supuesto, que la fuerza te acompañe.
Por cuestiones profesionales trabajé
en un proyecto de servicio comunitario.
¿De qué se trata este tipo de proyectos?
De aplicar lo que hemos aprendido
en una carrera de forma teórica
a una situación real
y buscar el mejoramiento social.
La oportunidad llegó acompañada de una
caja de libros que alguien había donado
para que llegaran a los jóvenes y
los niños de Chugchilán, una zona rural
que se encuentra ubicada
en la provincia de Cotopaxi.
Pero posiblemente esta caja de libros iba
a terminar empolvada
en algún rincón olvidado
de un centro educativo de Chugchilán.
Así que mis colegas y yo planteamos que lo
más adecuado sería crear
espacios de lectura
en los que podamos trabajar la literatura.
Con este razonamiento
empezamos a considerar,
porque Chugchilán es una de las zonas
con una altísima tasa
de desnutrición infantil.
Entonces la pregunta era
si estos niños
y jóvenes difícilmente se alimentan,
¿cómo hacer para que la literatura
los convierta en ávidos lectores?
Porque el acceso a la lectura es uno
de los derechos básicos del ser humano.
Sin embargo, la realidad es muy diferente.
Pero adversando esta realidad, nosotros
decidimos poner nuestro grano de arena.
Entonces, conjuntamente con un grupo de
docentes y de estudiantes de las carreras
de Literatura, Comunicación y Artes
Visuales, emprendimos la campaña
de donación de libros.
Más de 1300 ejemplares
de la literatura infantil y juvenil
fueron donados en esa ocasión.
Con todos estos libros nos fuimos
a la zona alta de Chugchilán.
Ahí, con el apoyo de docentes
y también de la comunidad,
logramos establecer una biblioteca
y dos rincones de lectura.
La primera vez que abrimos las puertas
de la biblioteca a los niños y los jóvenes
fue un momento de regocijo.
Los ojos de estos niños recorrían las
estanterías de la biblioteca en busca
de más y más libros.
Pero el proyecto no se quedaba ahí porque
además de esto, teníamos que dar vida
a esas, a esos libros
que estaban en este espacio.
Lo que hicimos fue trabajar
con los estudiantes, quienes plantearon
actividades lúdicas que integraran
la lectura, la escritura y el arte.
Muchos niños escribieron sus primeros
relatos proto literarios.
Quizás entre ellos se encuentren
los futuros escritores icónicos
de la literatura ecuatoriana.
Meses más tarde tuve la oportunidad
de emprender otro nuevo proyecto en el que
la literatura era el fundamento para esta
posibilidad de mejoramiento social,
gracias a la invitación de la escritora
Leonor Bravo y de Casa palabra biblioteca.
Nos juntamos estudiantes de la carrera
de Literatura, Comunicación y también
psicología para trabajar en una labor
que consistía en leer poesía
y cuentos para madres adolescentes
y sus pequeños hijos
apenas de pocos días de nacidos.
Sí, precisamente leer literatura a estas
pequeñas criaturas que apenas
levantan su cabecita y que todavía
no pueden pronunciar una sola palabra.
Porque está comprobado que a los niños
que reciben estímulos adecuados a través
de la lectura van a poder mejorar
sus competencias comunicativas
y también cognoscitivas.
Estábamos un poco temerosos al inicio
de este proyecto porque realmente no
sabíamos cuál iba a ser la receptividad
de una actividad como esta.
Sin embargo cada semana, durante una hora,
armados con libros de poesía
y de cuentos, animábamos las salas
de un hospital público
especializado en salud gineco-obstétrica.
Y déjenme decirles también que la poesía
surte milagros o casi,
porque tan pronto como nosotros
empezábamos a leer y a cantar,
los niños empezaban a calmarse
y tranquilizarse.
Los padres y madres de familia que también
estaban participando en esta actividad,
notaban cómo la cadencia de la poesía
o del canto y en su sencillez
tan hermosa, producía placidez
y tranquilidad a sus pequeñines.
Después de esta actividad teníamos rostros
de madres contentas y sentíamos
la satisfacción del deber cumplido.
Estos son solo dos pequeños ejemplos de
proyectos que ven a la literatura como el
caso, como el catalizador para el cambio
social a nivel nacional e internacional.
Existen muchas propuestas de este tipo.
Por ejemplo, existen bibliotecas
populares en zonas marginadas.
También tenemos clubes de lectura
en sitios económicamente deprimidos.
Se organizan talleres literarios y
talleres de escritura creativa en centros
de acogida, centros carcelarios,
también en centros hospitalarios.
En general, estos proyectos están
enfocados para trabajar
con población vulnerable.
Quizás no sea posible demostrar el impacto
inmediato de estos proyectos
que he descrito.
Sin embargo, estoy segura de que pudimos
cambiar y ampliar los horizontes
de muchos niños en Chugchilán.
Y además, también sembramos la semilla
de la inquietud de padres y madres que ven
en la lectura una forma propicia
para entablar los lazos de apego
entre sus hijos.
Todavía no le he contestado
a mi amiga.
Pero ahora sé con seguridad que le puedo
decir que la literatura
no solo sirve a la sociedad,
sino que también la transforma.
Gracias.